anlässlich des 61 jahrestages des tages
der malischen armee findet am
unabhängigkeitsplatz die koro circa 60
kilometer nordostwärts der hauptstadt
bamako eine parade statt
[Musik]
neben rang von vertretern der
verschiedenen malischen behörden
sicherheitskräfte und des militärs ist
auch der kommandant der education and
training task force im eu
trainingszentrum in kohle chor oberst
klaus schaden bauer als ehrengast zum
festakt eingeladen
als besonderes zeichen der wertschätzung
gegenüber österreich und der eu mission
wird ihm die ehrenvolle aufgabe
übertragen im rahmen des festaktes der
witwe eines im einsatz gefallenen
malischen soldaten die malische
ehrenmedaille zu überreichen
[Musik]
oberst jakober trauring der kommandant
des ausbildungszentrums der malischen
streitkräfte in korea und gleichzeitig
vorgesetzter aller in kuhle coro
eingesetzten sicherheitskräfte er nimmt
gemeinsam mit dem vertreter des
gouverneurs von curicó die parade ab
[Musik]
daran teilgenommen haben abordnungen von
frauen und kinder und anderer
nichtstaatlicher organisationen ebenso
wie militärische und paramilitärische
einheiten der malische sicherheitskräfte
sowie der armee
auch eine abordnung der education and
training task force der europäischen
training mission in mali marschiert
dabei mit dieser abordnung wird aus 20
soldatinnen und soldaten aus zehn
nationen gebildet die einladung zur
teilnahme an der parade ist ein
sichtbares zeichen der guten
zusammenarbeit zwischen der europäischen
trainingsmission und den malischen
sicherheitskräften